first of all a a great teacher really
loves learning really believes in
learning is a learner themselves is an
expert in what they teach and and with
those qualities they are engaging and
they also have to love kids and and love
the work that they're doing probably my
best example is seeing what ap teachers
do the teachers that teach those
students the a peek program and and and
what I see in those teachers is a real
love of their subject I see a a
commitment to the student I see very
high standards and I see them looking
for new ways to engage students in the
classroom so I think that's what really
i see in those teachers now as it wrote
as it relates to innovation I don't
think we have very much innovation in
education I think we've fallen way
behind in innovation and I think that's
one of the reasons that our education
system isn't as good as it should be
that we we still have the teacher
standing in front of 30 students
sometimes more sometimes less lecturing
rather than engaging them with all
that's available today you know I was we
were one of the large television
networks came to us with all of their
all of their news reels and all the
their libraries of of history and they
were looking at ways that they could
bring that into the classroom and we
were fascinated by we weren't we haven't
been able to really do that in a way
that I wanted to do that because how can
you how can you tell a young person
today what what was it like when dr.
King was was running this revolution in
this country it's when I saw during the
Obama
inauguration and leading up to it so
many pictures of the South when when
when there were hoses and dogs you when
when I looked at that it was hard for me
to believe that that that occurred even
though I lived during that age and saw
it well I couldn't explain that to to a
ten-year-old or a 15 or 16 year old
unless they saw it so there's an awful
lot about that would can be that that we
don't bring to students that we could to
really let them have a sense of of
history and many other subjects